نبقى مع فلسطين ومع صانع الافلام ايمن ابو
رموز ابن القدس اول فلسطيني يفوز بجائزتين
من مهرجان امي اورد في نيويورك شارك في
فيلم القدس في قلب الصراع والذي بثته منصه
غايس في مايو ايار 2022 وفاز بجائزه افضل
تصوير
مشاركته كبيره من مختلف انحاء العالم في
مهرجان ايمي في نيويورك لكن جائزتين ايمي
كافضل مصورا وافضل تغطيه اخباريه كانت من
نصيب المقدسي ايمن ابو رموز وزملائه بعد
مشاركتهم بتصوير فيلم وثائقي تحت عنوان
القدس في قلب الصراع
الشيخ جراح بس لما شفنا الاحداث في القدس
انه كيف صار في احداث باب العمود بالمسجد
الاقصى الفيلم يعني لما الواحد يصور فيلم
وثائقي بيكون هو بده يركز على شخصيه معينه
بس الشيء بيشدوا لها كثير مراحل ثاني او
محلات ثانيه جائزه للاعمال المتميزه في
مجال صناعه المسلسلات والبرامج
التلفزيونيه والمعروف لانها المقابله
لجائزه الاوسكار السينمائيه
القنابل الصوت والرصاص المطاطي وحتى
الاعتقالات اكثر مره كنا رح نعتقل فهذا
شيء عن جد كثير كثير اثر علي بعد ما شفت
الفيلم يعني اشي جدا صعب
هذا البيت اللي اخذته 60 لانها لاجئه
تهجرت ب 48 من حيفا هذا البيت
لانه تزوج وجابنا فصار بده مساحه اكبر بس
بابا انها بناء البيت عمرنا ماسا كان اجى
القاضي سكر باب البيت ورجع على المحكمه
وقمر انه البيت يضل مسكر
وهذا الصوت يوصل للعالم احنا بنعرف ان هذا
الصوت حقيقي والحقيقه لازم تظهر لكل
العالم فاحنا فرجينا الحقيقه عن جد يعني
كيف كان وكيف كانت القدس في هذيك الفتره
وفي احدث الشجره الحقيقه انا بنظري لازم
كل واحد يقدر يوصل الحقيقه كيف فيه
ايمن ابو رموز الحدث والقصه بعدسته والصحب
المشهد بكل تفاصيله من القدس الى العالميه
صباح العربيه